bios et squeeze aujourd'hui on se trouve
sur d'orwell the underworld un jeu que
je viens de trouver sur steam qui est
sorti très récemment je croyais dans la
catégorie jeux indépendants parce qu'il
est indépendant est ce que j'avais
besoin d'expliquer sa non v5 bien sûr
oculus rift non enfin où s est carrément
beau c'est une flamme au qui sait que ça
râle on y va ouais on entre dans une
bouche géante ça me plaît ça me plaît
pas trop donc là on est dans une sorte
de bunker si je comprends bien il ya ka
chemin bon moment donc c'est plutôt
[ __ ] pourquoi j'ai dit ça ya deux
chemins ici absolument rien rien du tout
le néant total le néant le plus con que
je peux accomplir auxquels je me
raccroche on sait jamais s'il faut se
cacher comme un rat un moment absolument
ras mais y'a rien au fait c'est ça le
sert strictement à rien quoi je vais pas
mettez des flèches au sol je n'aime pas
trop ça ah ok faut une clé faune qui
l'est c'est bon j'ai compris j'ai
compris de mets pas la pression avec des
bruits de portes métalliques
est-ce que la clé ne serait pas dans ce
bureau où elle est sur le bureau stock
vous l'avez dans notre poche items clé
ouvrira elle s'est aussi poursuivi
condren vrai une porte on est morte quoi
alors là il faut un ballon la station
c'est bien ça c'est beau c'est moins
aussi à quelqu'un là dedans mais nous y
qui pleure non on est enfermés dans
leurs matelas pauvre femme
alors je propose qu'on saute sur ce
[ __ ] de matelas on peut pas il ya des
bruits de pas des sortes de bruits de
paddock grands pas des bruits de pas
mignon de petits porcine et un ouais
encore un matelas ya un monstre
arrêtez-moi pas se mentir comme dans
chaque jeu devrait rien [ __ ] de monde
c'est sûr simplement on n'a pas encore
vu et c'est pas plus mal
un matelas waouh c'est pas comme si je
n'avais vu 28 je vais faire une
entreprise qui sera concurrent direct du
casse ça continue je voudrais des
matelas juste des matelas plein de
matches là partout et matelas au nom
mais mais qu'attend obasi à j'aime bien
mûri gami par contre j'aime bien ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'à un moment il a plu
en forme d'avion qu'il a avec le lance
comme ça et qu'on applaudisse gâteau ou
là j'aime pas trop ça il ya des marques
bizarre une lumière bizarre moi ouais
ouais ouais arrêter de mettre une
pression comme ça sourit koné allait
encore ma place à l'attelage par jour
qu'est-ce que qui me qui parle comme ça
déjà ce qu'on va retourner à l'école
ensemble mais à 36 ch mais le choix des
cailloux les cailloux c'est toujours bon
ok super [ __ ] calme je vous déteste
alors première porte ben bien sûr pas
voilà ils bloquent la porte comme ça à
du haut de son 3 cm saloperie de
cailloux je déteste le caillou à partir
de ce jour qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
j'ai absolument aucune idée de ce que
c'est a fait à sa tête ouvert la porte
qu'elle a tout simplement voilà alors
mon gars bah tu es viré
tu es viré c'est tout ça c'est pour se
cacher parce qu'il ya un monstre qui va
arriver je suis sûr ça n'a aucun sens
quoi
ni des wc ni une cabine téléphonique
donc c'est forcément un truc pour se
cacher un bain évidemment on est encore
pris le mauvais chemin
madame non regardez là il alors it was
the math gagne je n'aime pas ça du tout
je n'ai pas le code de ce qu'offre
finalement c'est peut-être le code par
défaut comme quand tu achètes une valise
qui est le zéro 000 noms pouvaient pas
être neuf ses coffres
le numéro du patient et 1305 os est si
c'est ça alors la sherlock sherlock 5
alors expérience neuf jours 11g compéter
l'amputation de ses bras et de ses
jambes
je ne veux pas savoir la suite fait un
origami avec une musique millions
d'euros on a la clé voilà parfaite la
station moment de gloire j'avais une
musique épique et où elle a fait non pas
tout de suite les feux des projecteurs
cela pour moi voilà voilà tourisme ou la
bafin j'aille dans le dans le couloir on
a vu une sorte d'homme meurs tu voulais
peut-être faire un paint ball avec nous
un s'accrocher à la grille c'est pas aux
eaux
est ce que je vous avais dit tu ne peux
pas le confronter avait marqué sa sur le
mur à l'instant je sais pas qu'est le
mec qui a cache toi mais je suis caché
reste loin de lui ça marche
je vous avais bien dit que c'était pas
des toilettes ou une cabine téléphonique
où es tu au mahb et qui en plus est
fermée [ __ ] up dès qu'on ait caché ou
10 steaks hachés steak haché ans il est
horrible
il vole ah non il ya des béquilles
bouger à droite là faut que j'aie la
droite mon gars tu m'as vu run faut que
je me cache ici steaks hachés frais non
non à quel moment ils ne voient pas à
youri brouillard des dat ass
non non non non mais peuple ça
m'apprendra à regarder les fesses des
méchants tout le temps c'est voilà c'est
scandaleux à y respire comme un bison il
a amené le vent vous a mis au point deux
courants d'air les ampoules s'affole
roche
mon jeu rame à mort un le jeu lui-même
veut tout arrêter or nord va t'en sa
respiration fait extrêmement peur après
peut-être que man on sait que c'est mon
père je sais pas mais bon j'ai compris
la blague ce qui respire comme dark
vador et dark vador dans le film ils
arrivent ils arrivent aux bâtards tu
n'es pas mon père il à gauche courant
réponse mais j'ai absolument pas peur de
toi à temps et va carrément envie de
nous obliger les fans ont conquis les
sur roulettes et yves à carmaux vite en
tout cas nous on [ __ ] on a un petit
coup d'adrénaline 1 où la vitesse
extrême alors ça nous mène où ça nous
mène où ces histoires cache toi merci
reste loin de lui je suis me cacher là
non il voit mon front c'est sûr ils
voient pas je suis là tu ne m'as pas
faut que j'aille à gauche
oui j'ai caché non mais attends c'est
comme les petits enfants d'autant que je
te vois pas tu me vois pas qu'est ce tu
as fait un bon gars il ya un bureau
entre nous pensez qu'il va me à l'effet
d'accélération de doc et l'aféas tu me
crois non et j'ai pratiqué le roller une
salle où tu as vu ce moustique carrément
aux rites quoi qu'est ce parti fois la
droite va cesser de m'attraper ce qu'on
peut lire que toi à moi moi j'ai
pratiqué skateboard mon gars on lâche
pas de skate et je fais la course à pied
mais bon faut pas se tromper
oui mais à quel moment acheter obligé de
tomber
je pratique le ski de bord n'est pas le
saut à la perche quoi cette manière j'ai
pas de perches on est tombé de carrément
ou un [ __ ] il a fallu un petit delta
plane pour moi je pense que j'ai avec
les sports la faut que j'arrête
ok fait mes gars saoul on voit
absolument rien c'est ça qui est génial
alors j'ai pris la gauche et apparemment
je n'aurais peut-être pas dû eux aussi
ont été inspirées par la gauche mais ça
s'est pas bien passé pour eux au loup et
soit tu ok pas monté sur les tuyaux
sinon il rampe et bah non il s'arrête là
bas on regarde bien on prend là dedans a
annoncé plein l'architecte de cet ordre
on invite tout prévu je sens qu'on va
bien s'éclater
j'ai un peu chanteur dans les jeux
d'horreur uniquement dans les jeux
d'horreur j'ai notamment fait des
concerts avec le malade s'il doit ou tu
l'as tu ok ouverture de porte pour c'est
que c'est un piège et qu'on meurt si on
tombe là dedans oui ce qu'on peut
peut-être éventuellement longer non
allez double fracture des gens dont on
va finir comme l'hôte après les cours
sur roulettes avec lui et tout à coup on
peut faire quelque chose avec ça m
l'oeil dedans non il faut un il doit
falloir ramasser quelque chose qui
s'emboîtent parfaitement dedans je sais
déjà drop et des flux pour se cacher
milan n'a absolument pas donc à que
dis-je
ben voilà en plus parfait tout ça
rebonjour jeunes trouvent
j'ai ce qu'il te faut attendre le temps
que j'accède à mon inventaire up et
voilà à droite il y a des engrenages à
gauche il ya une piscine de
1 m sur 30 cm en haut à gauche une mine
d'or et là c'est la sortie on va
commencer par aller à droite
ok bien évidemment il faut deux
engrenage j'ai besoin de faire une
épreuve de fort boyard tantôt sur la
gauche l'attenté une salle est ce que je
l'ouvrais marc dufau que je loue les
amis c'est pour l'association la foulée
tétouan vers la dette plus tard juste
qu'ils offraient ok on continue comme
prévu on ne change pas le plan on s'en
tient aux planches qui aurait vu dire
cette phrase merci pour le premier truc
je préfère le dire
là là ça semble méchant attention à quoi
va-t-il ressembler à un poulpe voire
même un poisson pas dit que l'on va
devoir passer par c'est un caillou
saloperie de cailloux c'était en poupe
top tube un bon gars c'est une sorte de
ténor me grosse tache
shrek qui s'est fait tordre en blanc
pour ceux qui nous a suivis peut-être
pas en fait c'était peut-être avec son
maître nageur il apprenait à nager ou et
shrek blanc la [ __ ] écoutez on va être
les premières grenades ball state or
[ __ ] à les items donc c'est dans mon
deuxième ça que j'ai acheté un chienne
parce que ça suffit avec tous tes sacs
[ __ ] ok premier truc fait qu'est ce
que ça change et on marche
william white blue water mais son bras
est carrément assez long pour m'attraper
là non la caravane job mais europe
métallique bas a réussi grootaers où
j'ai toujours rêvé de faire ça aussi
c'est comme dans les films d'action j'ai
à dire sur moi et je fait diversion
enfin lâché seul donc sous vêtements
débile est ce que ça aurait pas ouverts
partout hasard la porte au fond à droite
ici par nos micros dites moi que la
porte est ouverte ou qu'on peut l'ouvrir
sinon je suis bloqué non je sais suisse
a ouvert voilà je vois là voilà bien
évidemment il a fait le tour donc il
passe par là mais [ __ ] ça sauf
peut-être que je prenne une partie
d'agents métallique du mec pour le
branchement servant de pied de biche et
bijoux cette porte la clé doit se
trouver ici on y va moi je prends des
décisions je pourrais choses en main la
chose à dire il aujourd'hui plus tard là
je viens tout gâcher en n'étant pas du
tout viril en expliquant ça et là rien
dit là il est là il est beau moi j'aime
bien l'admirer un peu j'espère qu'à pas
faire le coup du sprint comme l'autre
mais oh
il appelle coup de fruits de camelot est
le tournant il s'est cogné avec un peu
de chance il est négociée dans le coma
c'est bon la semaine ou much bourrelet
omnium ventre je peux m'en prendre à nos
semences avions tanks les deux biches le
mot d'ordre est pied-de-biche
mais je prends vraiment pour un commando
qui donne des ordres à une équipe
inexistante comme alesi
je me prends pour les mecs qui gère sur
la route parce que moi avec une voiture
qui n'est pas une voiture mais qui est
chouette remix quoi mais [ __ ] folle et
me dire je te tue jamais faire ça à mon
bien j y aurait cette compétence c'est
bon ça et là il ya la clé à la place de
ce mec joue rh culture est monté sur le
dos chirac remix j'aurais fait du rodéo
allons nous en direction au nom au nom
au nom d'un bidon d'olmedo talent bidon
dans le tonneau barils dans le var il
tu veux un biberon date à espérer
alors là c'est les fesses de méchants
les plus imposantes qu'on ait vu c'est
clair net non dans le baril
c'est bien ça va obliger le dernier et
je m'en fais je m'en vais le poser dans
le trou qui correspond puis faire
puisque moi je suis spectacle où je fais
du mime au méchoui cette porte là voilà
ne m'en voulez pas ces partis up allait
tourner autour de tourner et alors
qu'est ce que tu as des biens au final
ça fait je suis ça fait monter l'eau
comme tout à l'heure si fait qu'on peut
accéder au portail court qu'avant vu il
est passé en mode remix culte ou le
travail à rennes ou comment on court
c'est carrément il réalise quoi on
dirait une sorte de fouine c'est à
droite on ouvre cette porte et c'est la
fin c'est ici que l'aventuré se termine
à chaque remise termina seul dans son
donjon et ben voilà c'est bien pratique
des eaux sur d'orwell the underworld on
aura vu deux méchants bien charismatique
qu'un homme sans bras ni jambes mais qui
savait faire du roller et un autre
méchant au fessier incroyable à un
potentiellement recrutables par l'équipe
de danseuses de beyoncé en tout cas
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
j'espère vous avez passé un très bon
week end et on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo chat ou le monde
pis